[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you hit the brick wall from those other
rooms first cake first try I'm actually
collecting the music though for this
video right now
rock music is like wading through the
deepest darkness dan give muddiest water
if you wicker it like this youtube.com
slash I am an eco audio watermark all
our videos like that the Sun is totally
fine literally an audio jungle totally
worth why I'm not saying we're not going
to find the song go to the one that has
a guitar at youtube.com slash salmon eco
like beautifully shouldn't even stop the
bad guy or not and away further thanks
first try if I make it into the hambone
jar Nika puts in a dollar
hey what first take first try
I'm doing sound design for Piderman the
classic sound effects that we have are
probably going to work for this except
for the hook sound and I want to sound
like it's like a really good solid
spider-man web sound effect pull tight
even though it's going to look like
pooping I'm using a new aperture mic the
shotgun condenser microphone called the
deity's having tried it out before I
hope it sounds ok quick thing about
sound design you have polling discount
effective background you have music and
then you have dialogue sound effects is
a combination of multiple sounds mix
together and adjusted to make a singular
effect so I'm going to use this one
spider-man
tugging on the rope fully choose the
sound of the character their shirts
their motions their step gym shorts with
some wind breaking material and what I
like about it it's sound sharp dialogue
is separate from Foley because it's just
their voice so what is this sound like
alright I want my ham going back
I'm gonna make it to the handle from
here I do I get a buck first take first
try use your dollar back man that was
really good
that's so easy and if that's how you
make if it's that easy to make money why
don't we just do this all day we have
new shirts in the corridor store guys
these are six like old school 90s nerf
log old toy logo corridor t-shirt it's
pretty sweet
I'm gonna wear this all the time and you
can too if you click on the link in the
description below we have a ton of new
shirt and literally picking music for
the video so Carmichael he looks right
now I'm Jessica music.com
such a bedico you get to like an
elevator and a trench coat and then like
a stencil in 2000 story of a building is
like a cyberpunk city within a lighter
like
Zig way to present a cute I've been
doing trick shots all day and it's tough
when you make every time you make
because this is the first day first
drive of the handle stop pick the butt
cheek why not ha ha ha I'm a mess
getting this up can't hide this okay I
think that legitimately is all the
sounds I could think of
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got new limited edition shirts in
the quarter digital store at crowd mate
calm flash court or digital you can take
a look and you can find these cool nerf
inspired 90 themes corridor digital
shirts they're on sale for a limited
time only for the next 7 days so if you
like their feel like our YouTube channel
take a look take a look at these shirts
also we have some new permanent ABS
which we'll be putting more of these
later in the year the event oh my back
rock Thursday first try way jig race
with toy business a cute I've been doing
tricks up all day
and
question talk about Sonny